the sky's promise rain but even when
they come it won't be enough
this is the worst drought the region has
seen in 40 years
and the threat of terror group al-shabab
continues their Fighters stalking the
edges of these camps nearly a million
people in Somalia have been displaced by
extreme hunger and more than half of
them are here baido is a town that has
many displacement camps and they're well
established but every day they keep
growing as more people arrive
close to half of somali's population is
now in need of food assistance
why did you come to this camp
oh
good enough
has become the epicenter of a looming
famine
the human cost of climate change
and its young children who are suffering
the most what's wrong with her yeah
this won't be the first time Somalia
faces famine in 2011 more than 200 000
people lost their lives nearly half of
them were children
Abdul Kareem is a year old and can't
even stand upright because his legs are
too weak to carry him
he's just been discharged from this
Center an emergency care facility
helping stabilize mounters children
but doctors here aren't just fighting
hunger
you have more cuff yes so maybe I have a
pneumonia so the issue isn't just hunger
it's all the diseases that come with the
hunger all the disease
with the hunger
so the doctors come out with with one
lady and her son and just as they've
moved on to one step of the process
another woman has just arrived for her
child to be weighed
checked it's just this constant stream
of mothers in need of immediate help for
their kids
how did the draw affect you
[Music]
[Music]
baby Osama is assessed weighed and
measured
the work is 10.2
what does that mean
so indicating this
[Music]
is
inside the ward it's a chorus of Christ
is it a good sign if the baby cries okay
that's good because if you need is the
time yes and it has that the baby has
the energy
he's able to cry so his appetite happens
how is this situation different to when
famine was declared in 2011. people are
going to be done because of the long
tatara so there is a insecurity and a
long drug so you think it's going to be
worse yes yes if it is going like this
it will be more than more than one yeah
it was here is one will be
it will be the serious work
it's feeding time and the cry is quiet
if the rains come do you think it will
get better
no because of the raining
it takes time
are you okay I'm so sorry
[Music]
for some hair help has come too late
just like the Reigns
they're from a shabab control territory
under a reign of terror the chances of
survival
drought hunger conflict
a battle on all fronts
Sky News Beethoven Somalia